now you were the odds on favorite to get
the Oscar for Cinderella Man that's what
everyone was saying did you want that
Oscar real bad no be honest no no it
would have been nice the thing I was
terrified about was if I had to actually
go up and say something what would you
have said I don't know no I do
preparation I tried to prepare something
did you practice a little bit where did
you do that in your house yeah like my
living room did you do it in front of
your wife or never no she would have
just laugh oh my God so like you [__]
doing that in front of my wife you found
a private space I guess I would do it
when nobody was around and sort of do it
in the
mirror no no cuz I would have I would
have thought I looked like an [__] so
you got up and you went like ladies and
gentlemen thank you for this award I
don't remember exactly what I was trying
to think of but I was trying to think of
like you can't just do the laundry list
of people's names that's boring but then
if you do the other thing you're really
you inevitably look like an [__]
right so where were you going with this
I don't know I don't really remember
thank God how far into it did you get
into the fantasy I I got pretty far I
got pretty far I got pretty deep into it
sometimes cuz there definitely were
times you're like wow I could win this I
could and I did I did think I could so I
better have something to say you
absolutely I thought I could so I better
not screw it up now did you feel you
know because there was a lot of when
sideways came out there was also a lot
of talk and then there was the big
snub he you didn't even get nom
the big snub yeah you were shocked about
that no not really come on I wasn't you
did a good job what was hard was
everybody being all like oh buddy sorry
yeah that was bad that was the worst but
I didn't actually think I deserved one
for that honestly really I think I'm
better in private parts than I am in
that M let me hear uh your academy award
speech I'm trying to think I what do you
say the second you get up good evening
are you a good evening guy I'm trying no
that would that would have been good
something like that did you consult with
anyone cuz you know a lot of writers but
maybe somebody could have read my wife
kept saying get somebody to write it for
you it's like no that I'll really sound
like an [__] cuz I won't be able to
memorize it or anything I'm trying you
should been like hello peoples of Earth
it that would great I'm trying to I mean
it wasn't anything interesting who would
you have thank would would would my name
have been in there out here I was going
to thank I was going to thank you now
[__] I was going to no no no I was going
to thank you yes but I was like who am I
going to lose if I thank
you like who do I cut and then thank you
and they'll get pissed me but I was
going to I was wow I would have do you
know that would have knocked me on my
ass great you would have fainted if at
home and when I did it in front of the
mirror all tearful you you your name
came
out